hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester we are back at the tata
steel india rapid addition it's magnus
carlsen versus wish marathon and before
we check out the game and it is a really
crazy game I would just like to thank
everyone for joining in the stream
yesterday and for joining the tournament
we had over over five and a half
thousand people playing in the
tournament the tournament ended well but
we did have some issues in the beginning
we kind of broke Lee chess but that I
guess too many people came and it was it
was too much to handle so maybe maybe
next time we will have better luck but
this is like the I don't know xx dream
we've had regarding tournaments and this
is the first time we've had issues so
you know it's it happens and yeah for
those of you who want to give away I
will put a list of all the winners in
the description below you can find find
out if you were picked even if you
didn't watch the stream for we have
already contacted me so as soon as I
verify the emails the Amazon giftcard
will be on the way so that being said
let's check out this very nice game but
first I do have two very nice photos
they are from chess base India so I do
hope you enjoy them here you can see
Magnus and Anand they've opened the game
yesterday between it's a critical game
between I believe India and Bangladesh
so the game opens when the big bell is
rang I believe I don't know if all the
cricket games start this way I don't
follow cricket but maybe they do if they
do then I guess it's not weird but both
of them just rang the bell and then the
game started and after that you can see
them here enjoying the show while having
some nice sips of water so there you
have it now let's check out this very
nice game Carlsen with the white pieces
opens with d4 with Knight to f6 by Anand
c4 and c6 with Bishop to b4 sorry Knight
to c3 I thought the night was there as
the microphone is in the way Knight to
c3 Bishop to b4 Knight to f3 d5 dollar
goes in defenses on the board we have C
captures he captures and Bishop to g5 so
nothing nothing out of the ordinary here
with h6 Bishop to
h4 end-run and castles with III by
Magnus preparing to develop the light
square Bishop and now Bishop the f5
Island continues development and not
night the d2 now on pinning and also you
will be able to push f3 e4 at some point
we have g5 pushing the better of all the
way to g3 and now c5 by island of course
he would very much like to open lines as
Carlson's king is still in the center of
the board with a three by Magnus Bishop
captures on c3 B captures on c3 and now
C for closing the the lights worship so
here Crossing has to make a decision
does he want to go Bishop to e2 and
castle or does he want this to be a
different kind of game and here at
Magnus decides that he wants this to be
a different kind of game here he plays
h4 he doesn't mind his king being in the
center of the board and there is one
game that reached this position it was
from the Norway championship 2018
between fro the orchid on and your young
Luke hammer our Knight B to d7 was
playing but here uh and the hammer was
able to win that game but here g4 was
played and it is as a move 13 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
what happens Anand sorry Magnus goes for
h5 just makes room for the bishop now
you can also go - up to h4 Bishop the f4
at some point you might even be able to
play rook to h4 - maybe threaten the
pawn so a useful move with Knight bb7 by
Anand and now comes Bishop to F for
threatening to capture on h6 and Anand
ignores it he just goes Queen to a5
saying okay you grab on h6 I'm gonna
grab on c3 your king is still in the
center of the board
Magnus agrees he plays Queen to c1 he
defends the c3 pawn and now Knight the
b6 just still ignoring this h7 point
although you could defend it with King
to h7
but Anand says nope Knight to a4 to c3
is well worth the h6 pawn okay Magnus
captures it attacks the rook on f8 and
here Anand just goes Knight a 4 he says
okay your king is still in the center of
the board I am NOT interested in in the
exchange so Magnus
doctors and Bishop captures we have rook
captures on f8 and now f3 makes room for
his King an f2 as it's very unlikely
that you will want a castle here so king
- f2 will be the safest square for the
king also you might be able to push me
for at some point we have rook to e8 the
king is still in the center of the board
and now kink the f2 guarding the e3 pawn
and here Anand still waits with the
catherine c3 he goes b5 and here it's
just the wild position crossings king
gun f2 aren't sacrifice the exchange
Anand is on the attack and here if you
if you don't have a way to develop your
your Bishop your rook your other look
make some use of the Queen your all of
your pieces are undeveloped so here if
there's no move that helps Magnus he is
he is in huge trouble but maybe there is
a move that helps him so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea that that Magnus found during the
game well I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do that congratulations on finding
the only move that gives Magnus the
advantage and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's efore yes it
looks very strange because well black is
just guarding well guarding the d4
square many times so it doesn't seem
possible but it is possible due to a
tactic Anand captures on e4 and now
comes the move you had to find its
Knight captures on c4 the point is now
the queen is under attack and also Queen
to g5 is a threat which would pick up
well either the knight or the bishop
depending on how black defends so here
you have to react to it with B captures
on c4 and the Magnus goes Queen to g5
tricks so he was able to develop some of
the pieces get the Queen in her game
that is that is what he needed and here
what do you play well you could go King
to h7 basically our king to f8 those are
the two good moves King to f8 is a
little bit better because after for
example Queen captures not the queen
guards the bishop so after Queen
captures on f6
you get rook the e6 this is the main
difference
and now after a let the Queen easy to
check your gonna go King t7 and the King
is very safe here and you do have a lot
of pieces
the ADH file here so it will not be all
that simple to push our H bond
however on and when to keep the h7 and
now it's a bit different here Magnus
captures on f6 first we have III with
check because now the f7 point is under
attack so you don't have time for route
to e6 with III check King to g1 and now
Russia back to e6 now the bishop is
guarding the pawn here and here yeah h6
is nice yes you do threaten mate but
look the g8 stops mate and now threatens
F capture G captors on f3
so it's hard to decide in such a move
there's always time to push h6 it's it's
not another problem so here first Magnus
pushes d5 now the idea is that you
cannot capture and c3 if you capture
just Queen traits and you pick up the
bishop here so you have to capture the
bishop if you capture with the bishop
then you no longer have control of the
g4 squared then rook here will be very
strong attacking the g4 pawn and here
even yes you do have e to which seems to
win a material for white but it doesn't
matter
Queen a5 check King to h8 and now a
Bishop captures an e2 and if you get
rook captures Bishop yes you win a piece
but rook a person g4 and now white will
a white will win this game with with the
row controlling the G file now the Queen
being very strong you can also get this
rook into the game it's just too will be
too hard to hold so here after d5 Anand
decides for Queen captures on d5 and now
rook the e1 by Magnus F captors and g4
is also possible g v g6 being the threat
but after Bishop captures in g4 still
hard to calculate although all the
craziness that happens after rook to h4
you have looked to g8 now Queen to f4
with a double attack when g5 defending
now you have to trade Queens and you
have to trade down into a superior
endgame but I guess Carson decided that
he can always trade down into a superior
in game so first rook to e1 goes after
the e3 pawn it's a very dangerous pass
pawn and Queen to d2 now Queen to d2
with a very sneaky threat for example if
Magnus plays a well a weird move like h6
the threatened mate or something
the queen f2 check King H 2 and G 3 is
mate because the bishop covers the H 3
square so on and uh well you cannot
allow that Magnus blocks it would work -
e - but now Queen the c1 and here Queen
to d4 just going after the e3 pawn and
here
Anand decides to trade we have G
captures an f3 Queen captures an e3 now
even though the rook is under attack if
you capture the rook then you lose the
Queen
so Queen captures on c3 now creating a
passed C pawn and now G captures on f3
here across and shows that opening up
the G file is not a problem for white we
have rook the g8 check King - f2 and now
Queen to g7 avoiding the Queen's right
here if you trade down yes you do have a
past C pawn which seems to be very
strong to play rook here start pushing
it may be but across and it still up the
exchange and it's very easy to activate
all of the pieces so it will not be
possible now on the greasewood as he
goes back Queen g7 prevents rook to g1
he doesn't want to allow Magnus to trade
even more pieces and here we have Quinta
efore with check with King to h6 Queen
to f4 with check King - h7 and now
Magnus plays Queen to e5 again offering
to trade down into a superior endgame
and Anand well this is basically the
last chance for on the trade he'll go
into the inferior endgame but on and of
course does not enjoy playing an
inferior and game against across and so
here he played Queen to h6 but Queen to
h6 doesn't work it's a very concrete
series of moves so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this winning
sequence for Magnus well I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
finding such a unique sequence of moves
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
rook the g1 you offer a rook trade and
also you will have now Quinta e4 check
which will be very deadly a rook trade
is favorable for Magnus so on and of
course declined the trade we have looked
the c8 but now well basically I could
have asked you to pause the video here
yeah it's it's even better so pause the
video
here and find the winning sequence for
Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds yeah that seems better so for
those of you who were able to do it now
really congratulations and for those of
you if you just want to enjoy the show
the move is Queen to e4 check and now
okay pink the h8 we have Quinta d4 check
King to h7 and here
Magnus just played rook captures on e6
and it was in this position now that
Vishwanath on and resigned the game and
yet another victory for Magnus Carlsen
and I believe he he is now over 3,000
rating performance and I think he with
this win and the LibraryThing list he is
again the number one rapid player in the
world but you know anything and still
happen I guess
so here you just have to resign because
if Queen captures Queen g7 is mate and
if you don't capture with the Queen if
you capture with the pawn well then it's
just Queen to d7 check and you don't
really have a move the rook is being
threatened so you could you could block
and then Queen Queen captures Queen is
made or you go King here you will just
deliver check here King moves and now
Queen to g8 is made again so it's not
just that you win material it's just
made so after rook captures an e6 Magnus
resigned and sorry Anand resigned and
yet another victory for Magnus I believe
this makes it four in a row so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it today
we I have a bit more time so we're gonna
cover more games and maybe cover some
from from yesterday as I didn't get a
chance to cover them due to the stream
so like I said thank you everyone for
joining the list of the winners of the
giveaway in the description below so do
check if any of you want the tournament
the the giveaway I would also like to
thank Morocco's own Parma Apogee Mahalo
van Chan Ho silver Aldo Ali jr. and
leastly McVicker for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel now rapid and blitz event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and soon we are starting the
next big saga thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent race to
your Sunday